hi everyone
this is professor m das science and
today i want to talk about
state collapse in another one of our
videos on rigorous quantum mechanics
we already know that before we perform a
quantum measurement
it is impossible to predict what the
result will be
all we can say is the likelihood of any
given result
today we'll discuss what happens after a
quantum measurement
the answer to this question introduces
yet another layer of complexity into
quantum theory
we learned that the very act of
measuring a quantum particle
fundamentally changes its state so let's
go
to understand what happens right after
measurement in quantum mechanics we need
to start with a refresher about
measurements
and for more details you should check
out the corresponding videos linked in
the description
the general setup is that we consider
physical quantity a
that in quantum mechanics is represented
by a hermitian operator a
called an observable we call the
observable a
to keep the discussion general but in
reality this will be something like the
position
or the momentum of a particle
the observable a abates this eigenvalue
equation
where lambda n or the eigenvalues and u
n
the eigenstates postulate 4 of quantum
mechanics
discussed in the videos on measurements
tells us that when we measure a
in a system in state psi then the
outcome of that measurement is an
eigenvalue lambda n
of the operator a and i will get that
result with the probability
p given by the absolute value squared of
the bracket
between the eigenstate u n associated
with the eigenvalue we measure
and the state psi we should also
remember that we can write the state
psi in the basis of eigenstates u n of
the operator
a and the expansion coefficients c
are given by the projection of psi onto
the u basis states
using these c coefficients we can
rewrite the probability p
of measuring eigenvalue lambda n in the
alternative form
absolute value of c m squared
this here is just a very quick refresher
of postulate 4 of quantum mechanics
which tells us the probability of
measuring a particular outcome of a
physical property
if it doesn't sound familiar to you then
you should first watch the videos on
measurements linked in the description
but if you're already comfortable with
postulate 4 then today we asked the
question of what happens
after we perform a measurement and for
that we need postulate 5
of quantum mechanics
postulate 5 tells us that if we measure
a
in a system in state psi and we get
lambda n
as a result of that measurement then the
state of the system
immediately after the measurement is the
eigenstate
u n associated with the eigenvalue
lambda n that we measured
so what does this mean if we have a
system in state
psi and we want to measure property a
then in general we could get
any eigenvalue of a as the outcome of
the measurement
all we can know before the measurement
is the probability of getting any
particular outcome
but once we've performed the measurement
then we get one of these possible
outcomes
say lambda n this is where positive 5
comes in it tells us that starting from
state
psi if we measure a and we get lambda n
then right after the measurement the
state of the system changes from psi
to u n the eigenstate associated with
the eigenvalue that we measured
this process is called state collapse
and what it means is that the state psi
of the system right before the
measurement
collapses to the eigenstate u n right
after the measurement
of the eigenvalue lambda n
this postulate has profound implications
and is one of the reasons why quantum
mechanics often appears so
counterintuitive
it is telling us that the very act of
measuring some property of a quantum
system
has a dramatic effect on the system that
we're measuring it changes its state
from whatever it was before the
measurement
to a completely new state if you compare
this to classical physics
where we can measure particle properties
like position and momentum
without changing the state of the system
okay so what we've discussed so far is
the essential idea behind state collapse
however in this discussion we've
implicitly been assuming that the
eigenvalues of operator a
are first non-degenerate
and second that they form a discrete
spectrum
in the rest of the video we explore the
mathematical changes that are needed
when we relax these two conditions
the changes don't affect the fundamental
understanding of state collapse but
they're necessary in many situations
let's start with the generate
eigenvalues
in this case the eigenvalue equation
needs to be updated to a
n i equals lambda n u n i
where i is an index that runs from 1 to
g
n what this equation says is that
eigenvalue lambda n
corresponds to g n different eigenstates
and we use the index i to label these
different eigenstates
in the videos on measurements we discuss
how the probability of measuring
eigenvalue lambda n
is given by the sum over the degenerate
subspace
of the absolute values squared of the
brackets between the associated
eigenstates and the state psi of the
system
again we can write this in terms of the
c expansion coefficients
in the videos on measurements we also
learned that we can rewrite this
expression by using the projection
operator pn
that projects onto the gn dimensional
subspace spanned by the eigenvalue
lambda n
what we can do now is we can start from
the state psi of the system
and then construct the state psi n by
acting with the projector pn
on psi once we've done this
we show in the video on measurements
that the probability
p lambda n is equal to the norm of
psi n in turn this can be written as
psi p n dagger p and psi
and then using the fact that p n is
hermitian we get p
n squared and using the fact that it is
also idempotent
we get pn overall we can write this
expression as the expectation value
of pn in state psi
again this discussion should be very
familiar from the videos on measurements
and if it isn't
check out those videos first
we're now ready to update postulate 5 to
the case of the generate eigenvalues
the updated postulate tells us that if
the outcome of a measurement of quantity
a of a system in state psi is lambda
n then the state of the system
immediately after the measurement
is the normalized projection of psi onto
the subspace
spanned by the eigenvalue lambda n
this sounds like a mouthful but the
essential message of the postulate is
unchanged
the state psi of the system changes
after the measurement
and it becomes a new state that is
associated with the eigenvalue that
we've measured
let's first check that this more general
form is consistent with the case we
discussed earlier
of non-degenerate eigenvalues if lambda
n
is nondegenerate then the projection
operator is simply the outer product
of u n with itself
according to postulate 5 the state after
the measurement
is p n psi divided by the square root of
the expectation value of p
n with respect to psi if we substitute
our expression for the projection
operator of an undegenerate eigenvalue
up here
then we get u n times the bracket u n
psi
all divided by the square root of psi u
n
u n psi this here is simply the square
root of the absolute value squared of u
n psi
and therefore the denominator cancels
with this bracket up here
the final result is the state u n
this of course is the result we expected
from our earlier discussion
it is an obvious result given that we
always work with eigenstates un that are
normalized
i just wanted to go over every step here
to make sure that we're all on the same
page
when the eigenvalue lambda n is
degenerate
then the pn operator up here projects
onto the gn dimensional subspace of the
eigenvalue
the numerator here is simply the
projection of psi onto this subspace
and we call this state psi n early in
the discussion
and this expectation value here is
simply the bracket of
psi n with itself this of course ensures
that the state we end up with
is properly normalized
the final thing i want to discuss is the
generalization of state collapse when we
have a continuous eigenvalue spectrum
in this case the eigenvalue equation is
a acting on eigenstate v
alpha equal to alpha v alpha where
alpha is a continuous variable
let's consider state psi and let's write
it out in the v
alpha basis as usual where the expansion
coefficients are given by the overlap
between the basis state
and psi when we have a continuous
eigenvalue spectrum
the result of a measurement cannot be a
precise value but instead a range of
values
if we use a very precise measuring
device we can make the range very small
but it is physically impossible to bring
it all the way to a single point
so in general we must consider the
probability of measuring alpha
in some range between alpha 1 and alpha
2.
from the videos on measurements we know
that the probability of obtaining this
result
is equal to the integral of the
probability density of the relevant
interval which as usual we can write in
terms of the expansion coefficients
moving forward we're going to call this
interval capital delta
the next step is to define the
projection operator onto this interval
in the usual way for continuous
variables
and taking all this update into account
we can write that if we start with state
psi and our measurement of a gives an
eigenvalue in the interval alpha 1 alpha
2
then the state right after the
measurement becomes this new projected
state
which again we insist is normalized
so when we have a continuous variable
state collapse works in the same way
but we need to update our mathematical
expressions slightly
the most famous example of a continuous
variable is position which leads to the
position representation in terms of wave
functions
in this example that many of you will be
familiar with will describe state
collapse
as wave function collapse
unlike classical physics in quantum
physics we cannot measure the property
of a particle without
fundamentally changing its quantum state
as you can imagine
this leads to some very exotic phenomena
so i encourage you to explore further in
the videos linked in the description and
as always
if you like the video please subscribe